women who work full-time still earn 15
less than men
but that's not because they're paid less
for the same jobs
it's because they're in different jobs
[Music]
women are in less senior jobs
in britain france and germany 80 to 90
of executive jobs are held by men
women also tend to choose different
occupations
in america over 80 percent of teachers
nurses secretaries and health workers
are female
and these jobs tend to be lower paid
primary school teachers in the west earn
nearly 20 percent less than the average
graduate job
nurses earn less than police officers
cleaners less than caretakers
[Music]
women are as ambitious as men
they earn the majority of university
degrees
in america they now ask for promotions
as often as men
but it's the price women pay for
motherhood that holds them back
in britain seventy percent of mothers
reduce their working hours or switch to
a less demanding job compared with
eleven percent of fathers
in australia it's 56 percent of mothers
and 19 percent of fathers
while in france 55 percent of mothers
scale back compared with 13 of fathers
when an american woman goes back to work
her salary is on average lower than it
would have been if she hadn't had a
child
the race for gender equality is far from
over
as more children choose non-traditional
careers and men do more child care fewer
working women will be held back
[Music]
you